now it's world counts a day and new
research reveals that one in two people
born after nineteen sixty will be
diagnosed with some form of it in their
lifetime at least a third of those
cancers cases are due to lifestyle so
are we doing enough to protect ourselves
from the disease I speak to GP dr. Hamid
Khan hello to dr. thank you for joining
us on Sky News this afternoon are we
doing enough to protect ourselves
against cancer well the short answer is
no the vast majority of lung cancers are
completely preventable they're caused by
smoking colorectal cancer which is also
one of the top three killers as it were
has a huge dietary component in terms of
risk factors and it's well known that
both that the three things smoking
alcohol and having a poor diet increase
your risk of a variety of cancers quite
significantly and I think that's where
our focus needs to be I think I focuses
excessively on treating and curing the
cancers which is a good thing to do but
a more efficient way of managing this
problem would be to work on health
promotion and public health and that's
where I think our focus needs to be as a
service as a nation and that's where
funds need to go as well we've had huge
public health cuts recently which
haven't helped that cause at all what
can be expected as a member of the
public as Rosie NHS is concerned and
what can we do ourselves well in terms
of what can can be expected we actually
have excellent protocols and pathways
for detecting and treating cancer the
national institute of clinical
excellence has very clear guidelines for
every type of cancer in England if you
have symptoms which may indicate a
cancer then you will be seen within two
weeks under the fast-track pathway as
it's called and we have some of the best
cancer treatment centers in the world so
in terms of what can be expected I think
we have some of the best treatment
facilities and some of the best pathways
that exist anywhere on the planet in
terms of what can we done what can be
done I think that goes on to a wider
quest
of rights versus responsibilities when
it comes to health care the balance
between rights and responsibilities will
always be difficult in a service like
the NHS which is completely
taxpayer-funded and which is free at the
point of delivery and universal but in
my point of view from my perspective
seeing patients every day the pendulum
has swung really far too much from
responsibility to rights and I think
patients would do well the public would
do well to think about what they can do
to improve their health and to prevent
things like cancer not just cancer but
various significant illnesses like heart
disease and lung disease and so on by
improving their lifestyle I incidentally
I have a lot of patients who I see who
have done this a good example as a
patient too I saw recently who had very
severe obesity and who wasn't very
concerned about it because she thought
that she could just have bariatric
surgery for it and that as a result of
that it was fine to not Institute
significant lifestyle measures to reduce
her chances of having dangerous obesity
in the emergency department I see a lot
of people who come in in Embree ated for
whom accident and emergency is almost a
default end to a night where they've
been drinking a lot for example and I
have lots of younger patients who expect
their health service to keep a diary for
them and to call them when they are due
to have blood tests and due to have
things like blood pressure checks and so
on and well that leads me to believe is
that we need to do more to encourage
people to actually empower themselves
and to take responsibility for their own
health because as a service and as a
nation we simply don't have the
resources to be a nanny state when it
comes to health to the extent that we
are at the moment yes we must provide
what is clinically necessary but
patients must also do whatever they can
to prevent themselves from becoming ill
and to improve their lifestyle and their
health in terms of things like diet and
exercise and smoking and alcohol and so
on
okay good to talk to you thanks to
joining us appreciate it